este hospital de lyon está haciendo todo
lo posible para recibir el mayor número
de pacientes con kobe 19 pero está
extremadamente saturado hay 52 camas en
el hospital y 23 están ocupadas por
pacientes con el logo coronavirus
tuvimos que liberar una cierta cantidad
de camas hasta el punto de que ahora
tenemos prácticamente la misma cantidad
que teníamos la primavera pasada cuatro
nuevas camas estarán disponibles a
finales de semana sin embargo la escasez
de personal es otra preocupación
importante salió se está volviendo
crítico porque estamos cansados y no
podemos conseguir el personal necesario
son en todos los hospitales de la región
están ahora sobrecargados y la única
solución es llamar a trabajadores de
respaldo de otros servicios de atención
el 60 por ciento de los trámites no
urgentes han sido cancelados y tenemos
que cerrar los quirófanos para que los
cirujanos vengan a ayudarnos así que a
medida que liberamos camas cerramos los
quirófanos y salió que esta enfermera
que trabaja habitualmente en quirófanos
se traslado a la unidad de reanimación
hoy cuidado un paciente que se encuentra
en estado crítico
todos los días el hospital ve casos de
infección cada vez más graves como éste
estamos empezando a ver de nuevo lo que
vimos en marzo es difícil porque es un
trabajo muy exigente y uno el personal
del hospital espera ver el impacto del
toque de queda de lyon en su carga de
trabajo pero la situación es muy
preocupante especialmente con el récord
de contagios que viene registrando el
país